yeah as we are reflecting on this past
year and i think about what this past
year was all about and it really it was
all about suffering and uh that's what
every year is that's what every day of
life is is suffering life is suffering
laughs sucks and uh one thing i that i
suffered through this past year was um
hr training videos
that uh basically my producer forced me
to watch
uh because again the sadistic people in
the audience and even the sweet baby
gang like to watch me suffer so we're
gonna go back and uh and now we're all
gonna suffer through it one more time
we're gonna go back and review some of
these uh hr videos and see if there's
anything we missed in them the first
time around let's watch you know one of
the great things about working in
conservative media is that i don't have
to take any insufferable
horrible diversity and inclusion
hr you know training courses at work
that a lot of people have to
be subjected to i've never been
subjected to that from our hr department
uh but many of you have had to endure it
so i thought that today
maybe as an act of solidarity because
i'm such a generous person i would
endure some of this training to see what
it's like uh just to see how
the other half lives and perhaps to
offer my own my own review of it i guess
shall we say so
this is from a company called mtrain
which according to the website
venturebeat.com is quota startup
providing online education
and guidance on human resources and
compliance topics
among their clients are dolby live
nation netflix yelp buzzfeed and the new
york times so maybe at your own job
you've had to sit through videos like
this maybe if you work at one of those
but if you're one of those places you're
probably not watching my videos but
either way
if you have had to to watch these i you
have my condolences now
m train has all their videos proudly
displayed on their youtube channel where
they generously allow you to watch it
for free so you don't even have to work
at one of these places to do it so in
your free time if you if you're
wondering
you know what you can do to be more
diverse and inclusive in your personal
life you can always go to this channel
check out their offerings uh they've got
videos on what do they got workplace
harassment they've got uh videos those
are probably good they've got stuff on
sexism in the workplace
they've got they've got some hipaa
compliance videos we might skip those i
don't know today we're going to skim
through their managing unconscious bias
playlist
how to manage your unconscious bias
because you can't get rid of your
unconscious bias you just got to learn
to live with it and manage it right
so they've got uh they got many
offerings in this genre we'll we'll
watch maybe a few of them today and
we'll start with this this is a video
called examples of unconscious bias
pattern matching
so the idea here is a little confusing
at first but they show us a scenario
and then you jump to the wrong
conclusion
about that scenario based on stereotypes
because you're a worthless bigot and
then we find out what was really
happening okay so that's basically how
this this works and uh let's take a look
um it's the dry cleaners down on a
mission
two blocks up you know yeah uh i need
the red shirt and we'll see you later
all right
okay
we'll just stop there for a second
because what the hell kind of dry
cleaning transaction is that that's what
i want to know so i'm supposed to feel
bad because i saw the two guys
whispering in a corner and exchanging
wads of cash on a street corner and i
didn't immediately assume it was a dry
cleaning thing
you're gonna blame me for that that's my
fault
no i'm not unconsciously biased for not
taking the dry cleaning possibility into
consideration initially that doesn't
make me biased i'm just a sane rational
person and i have lived in the world and
i know that usually when two guys on a
street corner whispering and exchanging
money it's not because one of them wants
their shirt ironed but very often sane
rationality is confused with bias these
days and the thing is it's also it's
also this is one of my problems it's
dangerous
to tell people not to make common sense
assumptions
in the world we do have to make
assumptions about people and they're not
always going to be flattering
assumptions
like if you're heading into a part of
town
where you're going for a jog or
something and you end up with a part of
town where you see a lot of guys on
street corners taking wads of cash from
random people and then handing them
unknown objects which they discreetly
tuck away in their pocket
it's probably safe as to turn around and
head in the other direction
rather than assuming that this is just a
part of town where everybody really
likes to have their pants properly
pressed
so um this has gotten off to a stupid
stupid start already as stupid as
expected i guess
let's try a new video this one is called
um this is called examples of
microaggressions in the workplace all
right so the famous microaggressions
we've all heard about them
now we get to see an example of them
let's watch this my hair looks crazy it
looks like a mess i don't believe your
hair always looks awesome i mean how do
you do it do you twist it do you do it
yourself yeah i twist it myself oh yeah
i mean do you mind oh oh yeah actually i
i do mind
oh sorry
but i mean if you're really curious
about it there are like tons of youtube
videos out now about natural hair so
maybe check that out
okay
so that that's a microaggression i i
still don't know what a microaggression
is i just watched an example of it i'm
not even sure who committed the
microaggression like there was a
microaggression floating around there
somewhere i'm not sure who it's
emanating from
um now i agree that it's weird for
someone to want to touch your hair you
know i i wouldn't want someone touching
i don't want someone touching any part
of me uh in the workplace and so but but
haven't you just made it a hell of a lot
more awkward
by turning it into a big deal and then
telling them to consult youtube
so you're the one who's made this
awkward it was already a little bit
awkward you've just ramped the awkward
up to level 10 now before it was like a
three or four now it's a 10 because of
you
someone says hey can i touch your hair
uh no but there are youtube videos for
hair touching freaks like yourself you
might want to check some of those out
see it seems like the response is even
weirder than the initial request and at
any rate how does that count as a
microaggression
the white lady was trying to pay the
black lady a compliment about her hair
maybe awkwardly but you know not every
awkward human interaction or clumsy
comment
or or even impolite action
is a microaggression
sometimes it's just someone being
awkward or impolite it happens it
happens in the world
in fact
nothing that happens ever is a
microaggression
because that's a made-up category and it
doesn't mean anything
ah there are more examples with this
video so let's let's keep going how do
people at work sit through this
and just keep their mouth shut i
wouldn't be able to do it
i couldn't physically do it
if you feel like you're not getting the
respect you deserve in life um well that
might be because you don't have a title
in front of your name that uh causes
people forces people to respect you and
here's here's something that you could
get you could get established titles uh
your very own proclamation like i have
declaring that you are a lord or lady
and you have this and you will gain the
respect you deserve i guarantee you all
you need is this one square foot plot of
land in scotland and established titles
is a project based on a historic
scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as lairds or lords and
ladies in english in your title pack
which i hold in my hand here you'll
receive at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate and
an official certificate with a crest
your certificate will include a unique
plot number with which you can see the
exact location of your land with this
certificate you could officially change
your name to lord or lady and you can
get on your credit card you're playing
tickets so this is like a legal name
change i am legally officially
lord matt walsh lord best-selling
children's author matt walsh establish
titles is having a great limited time
sale so go to established titles dot com
slash matt walsh to save 10 off today
remember to use the discount code matt
walsh or just click the link below
that's established titles dot com slash
matt walsh or just click the link below
so this has been uh this has been really
fun not really fun actually it's been
something it's been something at least
i'll say that
that much at least i decided that
because because many of you
work at places with hr departments that
make you sit through sensitivity
training videos i should both as a form
of um
as an act of solidarity but also as a
form of sort of anthropological research
i decided i should subject myself
to the same i found these videos on
the youtube channel of a company called
mtrain
which provides sensitivity training
material to a lot of big companies like
buzzfeed and live nation and i think new
york times bunch of companies they use
this company to give them their
sensitivity training material so last
time we watched uh their videos on
microaggressions in the workplace
and those were great today we're going
to take some time to watch some of their
teaching
videos on the important issue of
workplace
harassment this is an issue that's
very important to me um i am often
harassed
here at my job for example the other day
i wanted to go brew some coffee and uh
and i went to the cabinet where the
coffee filters are supposed to be and
there was no coffee filters i actually
had to walk
to a different cabinet to get them so i
considered that to be in a way
a form of harassment maybe even a
microaggression i don't know
i'm not sure if m train would say that
harassment or not but we'll find out so
let's start here here's a video this one
is on inappropriate touching
sounds pretty frisky we'll uh we'll take
a look and
see what we find out
okay great so pull the numbers from last
year and plug them into the report and
then distribute it before we meet with
christine tomorrow okay absolutely i can
do that
oh last late night just in time i need
to get back to the gym me too my back is
killing me it's like there's a knife
between my shoulders have you tried a
yoga roller worked for me that doesn't
do any good there's really only one
thing okay this is already heading bad
places but i see where this is this is
setting up
and uh i i i feel like i know where this
is going you know
i hate to ask but
would you would you walk on my back walk
on your back i mean
no i i mean i'd hurt you
my daughter does it all the time really
it's the only thing that helps i'd
really appreciate it no i can't do that
no come on it'll take two minutes it'll
really help me out
ah
come on i don't think i should do this
help me out
ah there you go
ah that's just stuff
that's it
right there right there right there oh
okay i have to tell you i i didn't i
thought i knew where it was going it i
didn't expect that that's not where i
thought
so that was it there was a twist ending
at the end there kind of an m night
shyamalan twist ending so i have
questions number one is this really a
common problem in the american office
environment i admit i haven't worked in
i was i was working from home for years
i haven't worked in an office
environment that much
i haven't seen anybody walking on
anybody's back here i can report is this
a common thing that comes up a lot
because i've never heard this in my life
i could just be naive do women often get
approached by men at work asking them to
walk on their backs
what other weird requests do you get
like hey listen hate to ask would you
mind uh hitting me in the shins with a
crowbar
would you mind it really helped me out
thanks a lot i appreciate it
uh i don't know this this seems like
kind of a niche grievance
this seems way too specific i just
imagine the brainstorming session at m
train when they were deciding on their
next harassment skit
and somebody was like oh i know
let's do one where someone wants a lady
to walk on their back
yeah let's do that one
dude you're telling on yourself a little
bit calm down this isn't very
professional the second point though is
why did she do it
see this is always a problem i have even
some of the the me too stories you hear
about and you know this is a me too this
is a me this this woman this is a me too
right now we're watching a me too happen
but why did you do it you could tell she
was she was very uncomfortable and she's
looking traumatized as she's walking on
the dude's back
just walk out of the room if you're
gonna walk just keep keep walking out of
the room walk over his back out of the
room
and then go tell someone and say hey
this freak in there is laying on the
ground begging me to walk on him
call the police
i that i don't understand i it you know
i kind of feel like if you're a woman in
the workplace someone asks you to do
that and you actually do it
then you're just as much to blame as he
is if i'm the boss i'd fire you both for
being a bunch of weirdos if i walk into
the room and see that you're both gone
i don't care that the woman has a
troubled expression i don't know if i
should be doing get out of here you both
your freaks
get a hotel room if you're going to do
that don't do it here yeah just as
abysmal as i remember i'm glad that we
could
experience that again one more time as
the year comes to a close really really
special moment that we were able to
share together you're welcome